Let's write down some pseudocode for
a sequential BFS algorithm.
This algorithm will take as input
a graph G represented by its vertices
and edges.
As well as a source vertex S.
What it will produce is
a map of distances D
where D of a vertex X is
the distance from S to X.
Now initially,
we don't know any of the distances.
So we'll initialize D to be infinity for
all vertices except S.
S is just zero edges away from itself.
Notice that according to this
initialization convention,
if there is no path from S to X,
then we'll get an infinity at D of X.
Now the algorithm will also maintain
a Q F of unvisited vertices.
Initially, F just contains the source s.
Now as long as F is not empty,
the algorithm does the following.
It first extracts an unvisited vertex v.
It then loops over all of v's neighbors.
Let's call a given neighbor w.
If w does not have a distance yet,
meaning its distance is set to infinity,
then, we will update it's distance to be
the distance of v plus one since
w is just one edge away from v.
In addition, if it didn't have
a distance yet, then it wasn't visited.
Therefore, we should throw
w into the visited queue.
In this example, I have given
this vertex a label of a and
I have thrown it into f.
Now let's consider the next
neighbor of the current vertex V.
It's also unvisited.
So we repeat this process of updating
its distance and adding it to F.
Now would be a good time for
you to pause and continue to trace
the algorithm, to see how it works and
convince yourself that it's correct.
Now what is the cost of this algorithm?
Since you traced it's execution as I
suggested, then you observe that it only
inserts a vertex into F if
it has not yet been visited.
Therefore the number of iterations of
the while loop shouldn't be more than
the number of vertices or the size of V.
And since each vertex appears in F at
most once, we'll visit each edge at most
once if the graph is directed, or
twice if the graph is undirected.
That means that the body of
the innermost for loop will be executed
a total number of times that is at
most big O of the number of edges.
In other words,
the total cost of the algorithm is big
O of the size of v plus the size of E.
Again, if you trace through the
algorithm yourself on a sample graph,
you'll see how this happens.